easy homemade spicy fake beans with
deliciously
light potato cakes
[Music]
the first big thing that i remember as a
kid was
bacon and beans so this is like a little
rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta ernie come on
disappear go and chase some mice now
panel get nice and hot
i'm gonna turn these beans into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly season that it's cured so it
doesn't need
that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how the individual tastes
of baked beans they're
somewhat bland so i always like to make
them a little bit more
spicy so a nice
finely chopped chili with
the seeds chili in
now a bit of garlic
crushed phenomenal
[Music]
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chili and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards slice across
then cut down to simply dice
bacon onion chilli garlic that flavor
all contained in that little pan once
you've sweated the onion off
a little bit of sugar in there the brown
sugar will start to caramelize
darken and enrich as well at the same
time
that looks beautiful now
a couple of tablespoons of cider vinegar
delays the pan
it's got that really nice powerful kick
to it now spice that up
with one of my favorite seasonings
worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your passata puree tomatoes
turn that down simmer the sauce to
reduce
then add in the classic baked bean
harrico beans
you can buy haircut beans dried or
canned they are packed with protein
and have a lovely soft texture turn down
the heat
and let the beans absorb all that
beautiful
spicy tomato sauce and just let that
simmer now
five or six minutes now for my potato
cakes they're a fantastic way to use
leftover boiled potatoes and are so easy
to make
i'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour
and butter to the mash that gives it
that nice sort of
cakey texture and it goes from this
leftover ball potato
to this nice light
flowery potato heaven
take a nice spoon of potato
lightly flour your board we're gonna fry
these
crisp on the outside and just
nice and fluffy in the center now
get your pan nice and hot we'll start
off with olive oil
into the pan
now put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up by the time
it goes into the center
it's almost sort of nut brown gently
them over
love that nice light crisp they look
beautiful
now take them out
cake in the middle and a nice
beautiful spoon of beans
growing up with beans on toast as a
treat
still to this day after all those years
has not changed
my love or attitude for beans especially
cooked like that
[Music]
my smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and creamy potato cakes
comfort and satisfaction on a plate
[Music]
a fennel sausage frittata
[Music]
the exciting thing about frittata is the
fact there's no set recipe
because it's basically eggs whatever
else you have left
for me the secret of a good frittata is
in the sausage
nice hot pan onions in
general from the onions heat nice and
high
season fennel seeds to give the onions
a really nice flavor everyone's used to
cooking sausages
whole but it's a really nice way of
using them to take them out of their
thin skin
what we're going to do is crumple all
that wonderful spicy
fennel sausage into the onions it's
going to release all that flavor a lot
quicker
pretty important to keep that gas nice
and high
and the longer you caramelise the
sausage the more flavour
you're gonna gain six
whole eggs give your eggs a really good
mix
flat leaf parsley a staple in italian
cooking chop it
quite rough some parmesan
it gives a really nice seasoning fresh
pepper
a little touch of salt
and then get it in there
when you fork through it so when you
slice it
no one's complaining they've got less
sausage i'm gonna make it even more
italian
by topping it with some buffalo
mozzarella
dry it and then slice it nice and thinly
twist it mozzarella in
and then finally finish it with that
panels and cheese get the top
just as tasty as it is at the bottom
my frittata needs three and a half to
four minutes under a red hot grill
to achieve the best results always
ensure your oven or grill
are preheated to the perfect temperature
she's ready this is the thing i love
about italian cooking
it's about sharing but always focusing
on the ingredients
look at that i mean it's incredible
a little shake the pan to make sure it
comes out and then
spatula underneath and just leave it
it's light fluffy and it smells
incredible
and that for me is a dream come true
it's amazing
how far you can take six eggs and two
sausages
wow spicy fennel sausage frittata my
ultimate italian breakfast
it's a cracking start to the day
your favorite chicken thighs first of
all
i'm gonna turn on the grill the reason
why we're using the thighs
are you the brown meat is so it doesn't
go dry season a nice
salt pepper olive oil
then turn them over please come on get
your hands in there
good don't worry about your nails so
there's no bones in there so the chicken
will cook
really quickly why do you do it inside
down
skin side down first that'll stop the
chicken from going dry
and it'll get it really nice and crispy
good see the way it's marked the skin
now yeah so all that really nice flavor
in there as well
and we'll turn them every two or three
minutes how much do you love chicken
lots lots you'll serve that some really
nice
chickpeas first we're gonna make a
little dressing okay
one nice teaspoon of mustard in please a
little bit of olive oil a touch of salt
and pepper give that a really good mix
and then just squeeze lots
of lemon juice in there a little taste
it's nice that is delicious
now look at that chicken now follow that
beautiful nice and crispy as well turn
the gas down now and leave that chicken
to griddle right let's get the chickpeas
done shall we yep
so we've got peculiar peppers so these
are roasted
smoked spanish peppers have a little
taste
i'd like you to chop up the
kettleberries
you take off the the top i'm gonna slice
them in half like that
wash your fingers oh well okay
so these are small tequila peppers yeah
a little bit sweeter there you go
put your fingers please watch your
fingers please tuck them in three finger
rule come on holly
you know the three finger rule i've been
telling you that since six months old
good girl you're fast aren't he yeah in
fact you're faster than jack
don't tell him don't get him upset shut
up at the purpose
yes please thank you good and then give
it a little mix for your fingers
please love it
rump holes out come on out
get out every time there's food is
always there he smells it from a mile
away
the chicken's grilling it's inside down
why is it on
skin side down because it keeps getting
moist keeps it really nice and moist
that's right
now we'll start the watermelon salad
watermelon
feta cucumber pan nice and hot
get the pecans okay and just sort of
break them up
i'm gonna start slicing the watermelon
you keep the seeds in
yeah these are fine so you just make
these little boats
and go around like that now with the
toasted pecans give them a little
seasoning would you please
with pepper too um no just touch your
salt thank you roll them around
and just start to see them smoking see
now turn the gas off please
we're just going to take half the
cucumber and give that a little peel for
me
please nuts are nicely dry roasted
take them off so from there i want you
then
to slice around the seeds and that's the
watery part
okay we'll keep that out wash your
fingers please
nice am i still faster than jack
you are still very fast a lot faster
than jack
now cucumber on top of the melon we'll
mix it up in a minute i'm going to give
that a nice little light seasoning
a touch of salt and a little touch of
pepper please
crush those little bits pecans in there
fine
nice next greek feta cheese
this is kind of easy isn't it jack
that fat and lump snoring you gotta get
him out of it hurry up mate take him out
fat lazy lump snoring his head off come
on out
so we've got that nice juicy melon the
cucumber and now the cheese
we need something to bring it to life no
taste
that's sumac okay that is very citrusy
we're just going to season that lightly
now what i want you to do is sprinkle
the pecans in there
what's that basil mint mint
minty you get confused with battle your
boyfriend
no daddy okay good keep it that way for
another 10 years
fresh mint over and then a little
drizzle
of olive oil okay don't mix it yet i
know you're dying to get in there aren't
you
mm-hmm and just some fresh lemon juice
why'd you roll it it starts to release
all the juice
let's now feel it so it's less firm a
little bit more squadgy
well it's all that lemony is coming out
now
what are we to do just have a little
taste
what do you taste everything yummy it's
fresh isn't it
so that's the salad done
next a refreshingly light dessert of
lemon and basil granita
start by putting the juice of seven
lemons and the zest of one
into a small pan with a sprinkling of
caster sugar
stir over a medium heat until the sugar
dissolves
dilute your granita mix with a little
water
[Music]
pour into a freezer-proof container stir
in a good handful of chopped fresh basil
and place covered in the freezer for
three hours
when the granita is frozen around the
edges lightly break up the mixture with
a fork
[Music]
return to the freezer and repeat twice
until the granita is frozen
with a granular texture spoon into
chilled serving glasses
garnish each with a sprig of basil
[Music]
amazingly light and refreshing lemon and
basil granita
with our granita and feta salad done and
the griddle chicken beautifully charred
we can put the final touches to our main
course
i'll take the chicken look how juicy
that is
see what i want you to do now with a
basil yeah it's the garlic leaves i just
want to tear them in there
there you go i'm going to start lifting
the chicken up please
and putting it in the chickpeas
oh that juicy amazing chicken
remember this little baby here a
vinaigrette
the heat of the chicken will infuse the
basil because the chicken's nice and
warm
melt the basil and turn this salad into
something
really delicious that smells so nice
doesn't it
see how we've glazed the chicken
[Music]
slide that onto our plate how
gorgeous is that got that roasted pepper
flavor
fresh basil those wonderful chickpeas
with a cake of berries
i think jack will like this one you
think jack will like this one yeah
yeah i'm megan and tilly really
interesting let's go well done
[Music]
this is my ultimate light dinner griddle
chicken thighs with chickpeas and a
lemony dressing
feta and watermelon salad and for a
refreshingly zingy end to the meal
lemon and basil granita
you